[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انها الساعه ستون ساعه
الايقاع السريع والمختلف هو المعلومه
المباشره الوافيه وفيها الكثير البدايه من
العناوين
تفاصيل الليله اللغز في روسيا تتكشف هل
طعن بعض الجنرالات ظهر بوتا لصالح قائد
باجنر
الملء الرابع لسد النهضه يضع مصر والسودان
امام سد ماذا عن البدائل
وايضا في ملفات الساعه 60
التعبئه العامه للجيش السوداني قد تحمل
معها تمدد الصراع انتشار السلاح وخطر
الحرب الاهليه
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي بيدا في بكين صافح
رئيس الصين وبيد اخرى في واشنطن افسد
الزياره صراع النفود متواصل
القوات المسلحه
[موسيقى]
الرجل الذي سنراه الان امامنا عصاره برفقه
خمسه الاف مقاتل في قافله انطلقت من دون
باس نحو الكريم
مع اكبر جيش موازن حقق تقدما في اراضي
موسكو في التاريخ تنفيذ مثالي لكن ماذا عن
الفكره يبيني بروجن من رجل ظل الذي نفذ
خطط الكرملين في الخارج الى متمرد منبوذا
قلب على عرابيه والاسباب معروفه لكن متى
ولدت الفكره
كريم يعني
[موسيقى]
ما حصل ليله السبت الماضي بقي لغزا لم
يفهمه الروس ولا اشد الاعداء لكن اياما
بعد الحادث تكشفت بعض التفاصيل تداولتها
مواقع روسيه مقربه من مراكز صنع القرار
الفرضيه الاولى فسرت لجوء للتمرد بسبب سحب
وزاره الدفاع لفار من جبهات القتال داغنر
دفعت ضريبه ولا تستحق معامله مماثله وهنا
حاول بريجوجن الاتصال ببوتان مباشره
مساعي زعيمر فشلت رغم محاولته المتكرره
منذ نهايه ابريل الماضي بسبب الحصار الذي
مارسه جناحه شويغو النافذ في الكرملين قبل
ان تقرر وزاره الدفاع حل فيجنر ودعوه
مقاتليها لامضاء العقود مع وزاره الدفاع
ادعى ان ثلاثه في المئه فقط من مقاتليه
وافقوا على الالتحاق بوزاره الدفاع والسبب
استحاله تطبيق خبراتهم القتاليه داخل جيش
الاحترافي ريغوجوجين رفض القرار وتمرد على
شويغو وشويجو لم يتقبل الرفض حسب الروايه
الروسيه واشرف شخصيا من رستوب على استهداف
بالصواريخ وثم بالطيران وهنا بريجوجان فقد
30 مقاتلا واعلن تفعيل الخطه صفر
الهدف من مسيرتنا نحو موسكو هو وقف القصف
الذي تتعرض له شركه فاجنر اضافه لتحميل
المسؤوليه للاشخاص الذين تسبب عدم
احترافيتهم في ارتكاب الكثير من الاخطاء
منذ بدء العمليات العسكريه الخاصه
مساء الرابع والعشرين من يونيو وبعد تعرض
احد مواقع فاجنر للقصف تم تفعيل خطه معده
مسبقا
جمع قواته في مكان واحد اعلمهم بان
زملائهم قتلوا بسبب هجوم نفذته مقاتلات
الروسيه ولا بديله لانقاذ حياتهم من
الانضمام الى مسيره العداله
وضع خطه مبنيه على دعم اربع شخصيات
لمشروعه
النائب قائد العمليات الخاصه في اوكرانيا
وذلك اضافه الى فيكتور قائد الحرس الروسي
الذي يعني يدعمه تحيد 400 الف جندي رجلان
اخران عول بريجوجن على دعمهما للتاثير على
بوتين ودفعه ودفعه للصف
امينو مكتبي الرئيس واليك
حارس بوتين السابق وحاكم مقاطعه تولا
الجنوبيه موسكو
انقسمت لقافلتين الاولى قادها بريغوجين
لروستوف والثانيه قادها اوت نحو موسكو
وهنا حدثت المفاجاه التي هزت
بوتين اختار صفاشويجو وحاضيه بدعم النخب
الروسيه كلها والسيروبوتين الرجل اصدقاء
في الجيش كان اول من ندد بالتمرد وهنا قرر
بريغوجن البحث عن مخرج اللبادلر تفاصيل
المفاوضات بقيت قليله لكن الرئيس
البيلاروسي كان شاهدا على التفاصيل
يعني ابلغت بوجهه نظر خلال الاتصال الاول
ولم اتصل به بعدها لكنه اتصل بمجددا ست
مرات طلبا للنصيحه احيانا وتقديما
للاقتراحات في حالات اخرى ثم قال لي لن
اطلب تسليم غراسيموف ولا حتى لقاء الرئيس
قلت له ممتاز لا داعي مستحيله واخبرته
بضروره وقف القافله حالا وبعد ان استشق
قياده فاجنر قابله الشروط لكنه عبر عن
مخاوف استهداف القافله اعطيته ضمانات بعد
التشاور مع الاستخبارات الروسيه واقترحت
عليه القدومه لبيلاروسيا وضمنت امنه وامنم
معه
مقربون من مراكز صنع القرار في روسيا
اكدوا ان بوتين امن بمبدا فرغتسد ولهذا
سمح باشتعال الصراع بين بريغوجين وايضا
اراد توجيه الانتقادات للشخص اخر حتى يكون
كبش فداء خسر الحربه في اوكرانيا لكن
بوتين ازداد تمسكا كونه دخل فتره يحتاج
فيها لرجال ثقه قبل الكفاءه امر اقتنع به
بروغوجين ولذلك كانت تصريحات كلها تتعلق
بالتخوين كان يوجه رسائل لبوتين بوتين رفض
الحديث معه عبر الهاتف ولم يبقى امامه
بعدم قصف قافلته بل سمح له باللجوء لبلاده
وافق دون شروط لكنه طالب بضمان اضافي
لسلامته والانسحاب قافله مجموعته بامان
ومن اقرب ثلاثه اشخاص لبوتين
سكرتير مجلس الامن الروسيه
ورئيس مكتب بوتين انطون فيانو وهذا سفير
روسيا في منسك بوليس جيرلز تراجع فاجنر لم
يرجع فقط الى اخفاقه في الحصول على الدعم
لكن هناك سبب اخر عسكري
قتلت باجنار التي تقدمت عبر الطريق السريع
ام فور لم تجد فاجنر امامها اي مقاومه
تذكر منذ مغادرتها
وجدت نفسها امام رفقاء السلاح الذين قتلوا
معا في اوكرانيا لكن الدفاع الروسيه وضعت
خطه لجذب عناصر باجنر في العمق والسبب ان
القافله كانت تضم 200 عربه وامتدت
لكيلومترات طويله تجنبا للاستهداف لكن
الامر اختلف مع اقترابهم من نهر اوكا تم
قطع الجسور اضافه الى عشره الاف جنديا في
الضفه وهنا اضطرت قافله فاجنر للتوقف
بوتين اعتبر نهر اوكا خطا احمر واعطى
الاوامر لضرب باجنر على حدوده وهنا اتصلت
الاستخبارات الروسيه
وابلغته بالفرصه الاخيره قبل ان يختار
تجنب القتال والعوده ما عدا تشاوره مع اوت
كين
ورغم فشل فاغنر في الوصول الى موسكو الى
ان بريجوجن كشف نقاط قوه وضعف لدى روسيا
في الوقت نفسه الخبر السيء لبوتين هو عدم
وجود قوه عسكريه كافيه لقطع الطريق امام
فاجنر بعيدا عن العاصمه لكن الاكثر اهميه
لبوتين هو ان بريجوجن اثبت ولا النخبه
الروسيه
فقد الامل بدخول موسكو بسبب عدم قدرته على
احداث انشقاق وهنا برزت نظريه ثانيه
مشاهدينا المعارضه الروسيه اكدت ان بوتين
علم مسبقا بالتمرد والجدل فقط حول الوقت
الذي اعلن بوتين فيه بنوايا لكن الاكيد
انه توقع حصول التمرد بين يومي الثاني
والعشرين
والخامس والعشرين من يونيو بوتين رفض
التدخل قبل انطلاق القافله والهدف بحسب
صحيفه ميدوسا التخلص من بعض الجنرالات
وعلى راسهم شويغو خاصه وان الصداقه
والتزامات بوتين بفريقه تمنعه من فعل ذلك
في الظروف العاديه وهنا ظهر دليل اخر
مصادر امريكيه اكدت ان السلوكيين مع
مجموعه اخرى من كبار الجنرالات صان دوبري
غوجن بعلم بوتين او بعدمه الكريم ينفي ذلك
لكن تمرد بريكوجن دون ضمانات من الجيش كان
سيكون انتحارا
اتوجه بنداء الى قائد فاجنر وعناصره لقد
مررنا معا بطريقه صعب قتلنا معا وتكبدنا
الخسائر معا ثم انتصرنا معا نحن دم واحد
لذا انا ادعو الى التوقف حالا فالعدو
ينتظر ان يدخل بلدنا ازمه داخليه
على العموم في الوقت الذي تاكد بوتين من
ولاء النخبه الروسيه كانت فاجنار تستعرض
شعبيتها في شوارع روستوب الروس علقوا على
المشاهد بان جيشهم الثاني في العالم لم
يعد الثاني في اوكرانيا فحسب كما قال
الثاني في روسيا ايضا
دخل مقر قياده الجيش في رستوف وكان باجنر
عادت الى البيت وبينما كان بريجوجل يتناول
الشاي مع نائب وزير الدفاع واحد جنرالات
الجيش نزل السكان لتحيه الجنود والتقاط
الصور مع من اعتبروهم ابطالا سواء بالنسبه
او بوت فرستوب ليست موسكو المدينه شهدت
تاسيس الفيلق السلافي عام 2013 ثم جاءت
خليفه
وكل مناطقي منطقه كوبان التي تمتد للبحر
الاسود جنوبا كانت اكبر منطقه
ماده بالمجندين
[موسيقى]
الايمان بخدمه الوطن داخل فرقه عسكريه
منفصله عن الجيش مساله متجذره في منطقه
روستوب وجنوب روسيا فكان المدينه هرعوا
لتحيه ابنائهم حاكم رستوف يصف هذه المشاهد
بغير الدقيقه قال نصا المدنيون الذين
رحبوا بفادمر هم عناصر من المجموعه مجموعه
فاجنر ارتدوا زيا لكن الصور لا تكذب هناك
ما جذب الشباب لباغنار ولبرجوشن الاخير
انتصر في حرب المعلومات على الانترنت حقق
الانتصارات ميدانيا اولا ثم انتقد فشل
الجيش وكلماته المباشره وجدت الكثير من
المعجبين
تحول الى شخصيه سياسيه تتعدى حدود باكلار
تحدي جديد امام بوتين حتى لو غابت بجوجل
من المشهد
ظل اسمي في جيني بريجوشن لسنوات مخترنا
بطباخ بوتين لكن الحرب الاوكرانيه غيرت
الموازين تصدر بريغوجن عناوين الصحف وباتت
شعبيته في تزايد خلال الاسابيع الماضيه
دخل لاول مره تصنيف مركز ليفادا للشخصيات
العمل التي يثق بها الروس واحتل المركز
الخامس
متفوقا على بعض من منافسيه الذين ينتقدهم
باستمرار مثل
الدفاع في اجابه المواطنين على سؤال طرحته
اقدم مؤسسه استطلاعيه في روسيا هل هناك
روس على قيد الحياه يمكن ان نفتخر بهم
ليبقى السؤال هل التمرد الذي قام به قائد
فاغنر افقده الشعبيه التي بناها على مدى
سنوات
وللمزيد ينضم الينا من موسكو الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي الروسيه اهلا بك اذا لا
تزال تدور الاسئله عن مصير مجموعه فاجنر
بعد خروجها من روسيا انتقالها الى
بيلاروسيا عن مستقبل بريغوجين ولكن
ما حدث في ال24 ساعه من هذا التمرد ايضا
بدات تتكشف تفاصيله وايضا هناك فرضيات
كثيره وهناك حيثيات لهذه الضمانات التي
جاءت مع هذا التمرد الاكيد ان الجنرالات
تحت المجهر الان فمن خان الكرملين برايك
هل هو سيروبكين ام سيروبكين ومعه اخرون
مساء الخير بالرايه الشخص الواحد الذي
خانه هو
بالفعل هو
طعنف الزهر في الله عندما كانت القوات
الاوكرانيه تحول ان يقوموا بالهجوم المضاد
وفي نهايه في نهايه المنطقه انتهت التمرد
بوتين نفذ
الضمانات وسمح ان يغادروا الى بيلاروسيا
وخاصه الضمانات من بوتين من لوكاشنك
اريد ان اقول ان رئيس روسيا هو يتصرف مع
خصومه على غير ما تصرف مثلا صدام حسين او
معمر القذافي لا يجب الغاء او التصفيه اي
شخص اذا كان خصما بالنسبه لبوتين هو
بنفس سابقا انه لا يتسامح مع الخيانه
الخيانه هي الشيء الوحيد الذي لا يمكن
لبوتين ان يتسامح معها وقال ان بريجوجن
ولم يسمه وهذا ايضا يطرح التساؤلات طعنه
في الظهر برايك ايضا هل تفاجا بوتين مما
حدث يعني هناك الكثير من المواقع للمعارضه
الروسيه مثلا جلاجونات يقول ان مخطط
التمرد وضع منذ ثمانيه اشهر كما نرى الان
امامنا على هذه الشاشه وهناك اشارات على
معرفه بوتين بهذا التمرد من قبل
انا لا اعير الانتباه الكثير من تصريحات
الوارده من قبل المعارضه الروسيه المعارضه
الموجوده داخل روسيه هي معارضه الجيب وهي
تتبع لبوسن اما المعارضه في الخارج فهي
تعمل ولسه الاستخبارات الغربيه
وطبعا تقول
لها
الوسائل الاعلام الغربيه
والسياسيين الغربيين عن شخصين اعتاقه انه
ليس هناك انشقاق في المجتمع روسي
وايام السته الجاريه بعد تمارط اثبتت ذلك
وليس ونقل انشقاق في صفوف الجيش اطلاقا
سيد
على الاقل التسلسل الزمني
هذه الازمه بين بريكوشن والجنرات سواء او
غرازمه نتحدث عن التصريحات توالت خلال سته
اشهر على الاقل انتقادات لاذعه ايضا تحدث
عن
هجوم مباشره على الشخصيتين البارزتين في
روسيا السؤال هل كانت هذه مفاجاه لبوتين
ام انه كان يعلم ماذا حدث وماذا سيفعل
بلا شك كان بوت مطلعه على الخلافات
الشديده
بينجيها
من جهه اخرى طبعا
اظن ان الرئيس بوتين ارتكب الخطا واحد هو
سمح لبره ان يشكل الجيش الخاص طبعا
الشركات العسكريه الخاصه هذا الشيء
المنتشر في العالم كله ولكن شارك اصبحت
اكبر الجيش خاصا في العالم هذا هو الصحيح
وفي اللحظه ما فكر بريهورن انه يستطيع ان
يملا الشروط لبوتين وان يبلغ له الشروط
الاركان ادى بما يتعلقوشن وايضا ما
تناولته واجهات كثيره عن مطامع له وما
ابهرته يعني خطواته الاخيره ولكن ايضا
يعني هناك ما يطرح التساؤلات حول
سيرافيكين وبحسب وثائق حصريه لها اظه كان
عضوا سريا في فاجنر ايضا يطرح التساؤلات
هنا كما نظهر ان تقول هذه التصريحات ولكن
ايضا يعني نتذكر في يناير كانت صيغه تسلم
لمنصبه كنائب لدراسه رئيس الاركان الروسي
ايضا كان هناك بعض التساؤلات حول الصيغه
يعني هو اقيل من منصب قائد العمليات في
اوكرانيا بعد ثلاثه اشهر من تعيينه وعين
بعدها يعني نائب لي جرازمه الاقاله هل هذا
يطرح اي صوره يمكن تفسيرها
لا اظن انه تم تغيير منصبه بسبب الولاء او
عدم الولاء لرئيس بوتين اول شيء اسمه هو
رئيس الاركان للجيش الروسي والمفروض عليها
ان يتراسل الجيش في المعركه اما الصوره
اصبح نعيبا في هذه العمليه هذا شيء طبيعي
وعن الشخصيه لا ارى هناك
الخيانه من قبل
خاصه
تتكلم ولكن لا تقدموا اي اثبات الكلام
بدون الاثبات هذا هو كلام فارغ الصوف
الصفراء تتصرف كذلك للاسف الشديد الصحف
الصحف الامريكيه المحترم تحولت للسوق الى
الصحف الصفراء هذا
نعم اشكرك جزيل الشكر كنت معنا من موسكو
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي اندريه مرتزين
ماذا لو انهارا سد النهضه في الساعه بعد
دقيقه
اهلا بكم من جديد مشروع قومي حلم اثيوبي
يتحقق على حساب مصر والسودان وامنهما
المائي والاخطر الوجودي هكذا كان سد
النهضه بالنسبه للدول الافريقيه الثلاث
منذ وضع حجر اساسه في 2011 وهكذا سيبقى
واثيوبيا تشارك على خطوه الملء الاخيره
للسد ابتداء من يوليو وحتى منتصف سبتمبر
المقبل نقطه اللاعوده والامر الواقع
والاخيارات للقاهره والخرطوم وهذه الاخيره
المنشغله في حربها الداخليه سوى القبول
بما فرضته اديس ابابا من خطوات احاديه
لاتمام مشروعها طوال سنوات كانت مخاوف
دولتي المصب للنيل تدور حول الاثار
السلبيه لسد النهضه برزت في جولات
المفاوضات وعشرات الجلسات العاتره دون
جدوى ازمه السد وصلت الى سد ورحل ملفها
الى مجلس الامن
2022 الذي عقد جلستين حول الموضوع دون
اتخاذ قرارا بشانه والتعبئه الرابعه
المرتقبه الاكثر خطوره كونها تستهد
ف سوبا من المياه ولا المفارقه لن يكون
لها تاثير تماما كسابقاتها من وجهه النظر
الاثيوبيه
سد النهضه يقترب الان من التعبئه الرابعه
التعبئات الثلاث السابقه لم تحدث ضررا
بدول المصب وكذلك ستكون التعبئه الرابعه
بالنسبه لاديس ابابا الانجاز وتحقق رغم
الضغوط الدبلوماسيه ومواسم الشحوه حرب
اقليميه التي عرقلت عددا من منشات اثيوبيا
التحتيه لكن الملا الرابع لا تحتمله بنيه
السدا بحسب خبراء واولادات في 2011 اللجنه
الدوليه اثناء معاينه السد حينها اكدت انه
وضعه مرعب ومخيف اثار ذلك قلق واشنطن
والبنك الدولي منذ ذلك الحين ولكن لماذا
سد النهضه يواجه بالاساس خطرا انهيار
بنسبه 50% مشاهدين وبالمناسبه اثيوبيا
ترفض حتى اليوم الكشف عن معامل امان السد
رغم توقيعها مع مصر والسودان في عام 2015
لتحديد اليات حل مشاكل كل المشاكل
المتعلقه بسد النهضه وما كان خطرا على
الورق وحبرا في تقارير اصبح تحديدا محدقا
مع الملء المرتقب والتشغيل فيما بعد
[موسيقى]
ملؤوا سد النهضه المرتقى يهدف الى تخزين
اربعين مليار متر مكعب من المياه بالنتيجه
وبعد ثلاث عمليات تعبئه بدات منذ منتصف
عام 2020 تجري خطوات اثيوبيا بحسب الخطه
نحو تحقيق الهدف النهائي ملء خزان سد
النهضه بمجموع 74 مليار متر مكعب من
المياه وسنعود الى هذا الرقم بعد قليل
عمليا وبقراءه تقنيه للملء الرابع انخفض
مستوى بحيره السد الاثيوبي بنحو عشره
امتار بين التبخر والتسرب في التربه كما
اظهرت صور اقمار صناعيه تفريغ مياه بنحو
سبعه مليارات متر مكعب وهذا يمهد لزياده
اثيوبيا ارتفاع الممر الاوسط الذي يعترض
مجرى المياه ويحجزها استعدادا للتخزين
المرتقب وبناء على هذا الارتفاع الذي
قررته اثيوبيا سيكون الملا بالمناسبه هي
لا تعلن ابدا ولم يحدث ان اعلنت عن الكميه
المستهدفه لملء طوال السنوات الثلاث
الماضيه وهذه ازمه كبيره للسودان ومصر
فعندما انهت اديس ابابا الملا الثالث
الثالث في اسبوعين على غير المتوقع بسبب
غزاله الامطار ومياه الفيضان تضرر سدي
السودان الرصيرس وصنار ولانه من المفترض
ان يفرغا مخزون الخزانات ليستقبل المياه
الوارده اليهما من اثيوبيا الملا الرابع
يفترض ان ينتهي بعد تخزين 40 مليار متر
مكعب بما فيه حصول السودان على حصتها وقد
تنشا ازمه بين القاهره والخرطوم حينها على
نحو تسعه مليارات متر مكعب تنقص مصر بعد
انتهاء التعبئه الاثيوبيه هذه ازمه نقص
المياه هو سنعود اليها ولكن لا يزال الخطر
الاكبر قائما كارثه الانهيار ان وقعت مش
اهدينا ستبدو موجات تسونامي مجرد العاب
مائيه وهذه ليست مبالغه من الساعه ستون
فالمنسوب المستهدف لملء سد النهضه بالكامل
يعادل 30 مليون مسبح اولمبي
[موسيقى]
مما تتخوف مصر في الحقيقه لديها الكثير من
الازمات وستتعاظم مع سد النهضه حتى قبل
تشغيله عمليات سوف تتسبب في اضرار نتيجه
نتيجه حجج السد لكميات الطميه التي كانت
تاتي مع المياه بدون تدخل وتساهم في تخصيب
الاراضي الزراعيه المصريه الخساره المائيه
بالاساس تعادل اجماليه ما تم تخزينه خلال
السنوات الثلاث السابقه وتتجاوز 17 مليار
متر مكعب والملء الثالث الذي تقول اديس
ابابا انه لم يؤثر على مصر تسبب في نقص
ملحوظ بانتاج الكهرباء السد العالي نتيجه
انخفاض منسوب بحيره ناصر
الترجيحات تتحدث عن خساره مصر حوالي 18
الى 25 مليار متر مكعب نتيجه ملء السد في
اربع مراحل لنوضح الامر اكثر اذا فقدان
مصر لمليار متر مكعب من المياه يعني خساره
مليار دولار سنويا في مجال الزراعه
والتقديرات تتحدث عن خساره اكثر من مليون
ومئه الف شخص لاعمالهم بفقدان 15% تقريبا
من الرقعه الزراعيه في مصر ولكل ذلك
تداعيات بالطبع زياده الازمات الاجتماعيه
والاقتصاديه تفاقم الهجره غير المنظمه
واحتمال المضاعفه فاتوره واردات مصر
الغذائيه
[موسيقى]
ومن القاهره ينضم الينا الدكتور عباس
شراقي استاذ الجيولوجيا والموارد المائيه
في جامعه القاهره اهلا بك اذا الدكتور
يعني السؤال الاهم في كل هذا الازمه كبيره
سد النهضه يمثل تهديدا وجوديا ولكن هل
يلمس المصريون اي تداعيات من مراحل
الثلاثه السابقه وهل سيتاثر المصريون
بالملا الرابع كما يقول الخبراء وتنفي
اثيوبيا
تحياتي لحضرتك وكل الساده المشاهدين هو
عندما نتحدث عن
اثار سد النهضه
وتاثيره على المواطن المصري
الدوله بتعمل على عدم وصول الضرر الى
المواطن عن طريق مصر لديها السد العالي
هذا هذا السد به مخزون مائي تحاول الدوله
المصريه طوال السنوات الماضيه زياده هذا
المخزون تحسبا للتخزين في سد النهضه وايضا
ممكن مصر تتعرض او منطقه حوض النيل تتعرض
لفتره جفاف وهذا تعودناه في على مدار
تاريخ نهر النيل من سنوات سيمان وسنوات
عجاف اذا السد العالي بمخزونه وزياده هذا
المخزون عن طريق بعض المشروعات الكبيره
التي اقامتها الدوله في السنوات الاخيره
منها محطات لمعالجه مياه الصرف الزراعي
واعاده استخدامها مرتين وتلاته منها تطوير
الزراعه وتطوير الري من الري بالغمر الى
الري الحديث منها استبدال بعض المحاصيل
الشارقه بالمياه زي قصب السكر
المشاريع دكتور هي مشاريع لتدارك
التهديدات تدارك المخاطر لسد النهضه يعني
التقارير تشير الى ان السد العالي في
الملا الثالث تاثر من ناحيه توليد
الكهرباء وهناك ايضا يعني اضرار اخرى
لاحقت بحسب التقارير بالاراضي الزراعيه هل
هذا صحيح
لا السد العالي يمنع وصول الضرر الى
المواطن ولكن هنا الدوله علشان الضرر هذا
لا يصل لازم ان نزود مخزون السد العالي
زياده المخزون تتطلب مشروعات بعشرات
المليارات من الدولارات وهذا ما تم بالفعل
خلال السنوات الماضيه التخزين الرابع
القادم اللي هيبدا في منتصف يوليو القادم
هذا التخزين مختلف لان كميته كبيره قد تصل
الى 25 مليار متر مكعب هذه الكميه تعتبر
نصف حصه النيل الازرق بالكامل وايضا تقترب
من نصف حصه مصر الثانويه وهذه الكميه 25
مليار متر مكعب بتروي 5 مليون فدان في مصر
بيعيش عليها اكثر من 25 مليون مصري
بالاضافه الى انها بتساهم باكثر من 50% من
الامن الغذائي للمصريين هذه المياه حجزها
في اثيوبيا كان هيبقى
كبيره على الشعب المصري
مطالبه مصر بالزام اثيوبيا باتفاق يعني
يستند الى القوانين القانون الدولي ولكن
من ناحيه النقاط التقنيه يعني او الناحيه
التقنيه ما هي اهميه ان تجبر اثيوبيا او
ان تخبر اثيوبيا دول المصاب بكميه المياه
التي تريد تخزينها وايضا بموعد تخزين
المياه في سد النهضه
السدود التي تنشا على نهر واحد لابد ان
يكون بينها تنسيق بالظبط زي ما حطات السكه
الحديد القطر عشان ينتقل من محطه الى اخرى
لابد من العلم فايضا مياه النهر عندما
تنتقل من سد النهضه الى سد روسيه في
السودان ثم سونار وغيره من السدود الى ان
يصل الى السد العالي لابد من التنسيق لابد
من معرفه كميه المياه التي سوف تاتي خلال
الاسابيع او الشهور القادمه لكي لان هناك
ترتيبات هندسيه في تفريغ للسدود لاستقبال
المياه الجديده وفيه الابقاء على جزء من
المياه في السدود لاستخدامها وقت التخزين
ولكن عدم التنسيق ده بيعمل ارتباك شديد في
تشغيل السدود وشفنا في التخزين الاول في
2020 اثيوبيا منعت وصول المياه الى
السودان لمده 21 يوم في خلال هذه الفتره
النيل الازرق المنسوب منخفض لان المياه
استهلكت ومحطات مياه لم تجد مياه وخرجت عن
الخدمه وكانت مشكله كبيره للمدن في
السودان وبالتالي هنا
ولذلك اثيوبيا حاليا سايبه بوابه صغيره
بتفرغ جزء من المياه حتى لا يتعرض السودان
كما تعرض في التخزين الاول ولكن يظل كميه
التخزين اللي احنا بنستنتج ان كميه
التخزين القادم 25 مليار لكن ليس هناك
تبادل معلومات وليس هناك اتفاق على هذا
التخزين كان في في المشاورات السابقه ان
يبقى التخزين عشره مليار سنويا ولكن الان
مره اثيوبيا تخزن تلاته ومره تخزن تسعه
ومره تخزن السنه دي لو خزينه 25
ضخم جدا وشكرا التاثير على السد نعم شكرا
كنت معنا من القاهره الدكتور عباس الشراقي
استاذ الجيولوجيا والموارد المائيه في
جامعه القاهره
[موسيقى]
اكثر من ثلاثه اشهر مرت على النزاع في
السودان ولا تزال المعاناه قائمه عدد
الفرينه للدول المجاوره بلغ اكثر من مليون
شخص بحسب مفوضيه الامم المتحده لشؤون
اللاجئين الامان غائب تحولت البلاد الى
مدينه اشباح ولا يبدو ان الوضع يسير نحو
التحسن رئيس مجلس السياده السودانيه عبد
الفتاح البرهان اعلن حاله التعبئه العامه
اول خطاب متلفز له منذ اندلاع الازمه ظهر
فيه بالزي العسكري ودعا كل من يستطيع حمل
السلاح الى الانضمام للقوات المسلحه
علم المؤامره يتطلب من الجميع ان يرغ
والاستعداد للتصدي للمهددات الوجوديه
لدولتنا لذلك نطلب من جميع شباب بلادي وكل
من يستطيع الدفاع ان لا يتردد او يتاخر
بان يقوم بهذا الدور الوطني في مكان سكنه
او بالانضمام للحياه العسكريه
لنيل شرف الدفاع عن بقاء الدوله السودانيه
التي تداعد عليها المؤامرات داخليا
وخارجيا
اعلان البرهان الذي تابعناه هل يمكن ان
يحل النزاع في السودان الاجابه لا فكل
حروب السودان لم تحل الا عبر التفاوض وهذا
ما يراه المتحدث باسم العمليه السياسيه
خالد عمرو يوسف لكن لماذا جاء اعلان
البرهان في هذا الوقت هل بسبب نقص العناصر
لناخذ الخرطوم كمثال يمكن بالكاد رؤيه
كتائب المشاه التابعه للجيش رغم انه يتكون
من 200 الف جندي لكن رغم ذلك فسبب قد يكون
لامر اخر يريد الجيش من الشباب شباب
الاحياء المساهمه في اخراج قوات الدعم من
بين المدنيين الى ميدان المعركه حيث يشتكي
المواطنون من انتهاكات من القوات الدعم
السريع بحقهم وبالمناسبه اعلن حميدتي قبل
ايام تشكيل لجنه ومحكمه ميدانيه من اجل
محاسبه مرتكبي هذه الانتهاكات ليس الخوف
ليس من القرار قرار اعلان التعبئه العامه
وانما من تبعاته بحسب دبلوماسيين غربيين
السلاح قد يكون في متناول الجميع ولنا
فيما حدث عام 2003 عبره
[موسيقى]
في مقابل اعلاني التعبئه العامه من قبل
الجيش هناك خطوات من الدعم السريع باتت في
يدها قياده شرطه الاحتياطيه المركزي في
الخرطوم تعد حميه ظهر القوات المسلحه
واحدى اكثر القواعد تحصينا في العاصمه
سيطره قد توتيل هي الاخرى امد الصراع في
السودان
بالنسبه لمساله
نعم المعارك الذي تدار اليوم فقط وهي هذه
المعركه بالاحرى بدات من يوم امس واستمرت
قرابه الثلاثين ساعه من اشد واشرس المعارك
على الاطلاق لكن بحمد الله وتوفيقه ان
استطعت وتدعم السريع ان تسيطر تماما على
كل المعسكر وفي كل الياته ومقوماته استلمت
فيهما لا يقل عن 100 وعشره دبابه او او
مدرعه وكل الاليات يعني انا لا استطيع ان
اعطيك الرقم النهائي لكن الان هو تماما
تحت سيطره القوات الدعم السريع
الدعم السريع وجدت ضلتها في معسكر
الاحتياط المركزي قد تكون نقطه تحول في
النزاع الذي يمتد لي اماكن اخرى فهي ليست
فقط قاعده تابعه للجيش بل ان اهميتها
استراتيجيه حاولت دعم السريع منذ بدايه
الصراع امتلاكها
تمحت قوات الدعم السريع موقعا ضخما ومحصنا
جنوبي الخرطوم كما ان الموقع يسخر
بالاسلحه والاليات الخفيفه ما يتناسب مع
اسلوب الدعم السريع في قتال المدن القاعده
تم تجهيزها واعدادها بشكل جيد لتكون يد
الجيش الضاربه تقع على الطريق الواصل بين
المعسكر الرئيسي لقوات الدعم السريع في
طيبه جنوبيه الخرطوم ومعسكرات الجيش في
وسط الخرطوم سيطره الدعم السريع عليها
يعني قطع الدعم الذي قد يحتاجه الجيش في
الجنوب حيث ولايات النيل الازرق وكوردفان
ودرفور
بالنسبه لح
الله اكبر
لماذا يتنافس عمالقه التكنولوجيا على حقوق
بث رياضه المختلفه الساعه بعد دقيقه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد بعدها اقل من ثمان
واربعين ساعه على زياره اولى لوزير خارجيه
امريكي الى الصين منذ خمس سنوات والتي
جاءت لتهدئه التوترات خرج رئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن ليصف نظيره الصيني الديكتاتور
حينها بداوا وكان جهود بلينكن قد ذهبت سدا
لكن وزارته هومنت من الامر
بعدها بايام خرج بلينكن بنفسها توقع
الجميع انه سيكون دبلوماسيا لتهدئه الغضب
الصيني من حديث بايدن لكن حدثت المفاجاه
اذا بهذه التصريحات افسد بايدن وبلينكن
مهمه وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه الاستثنائيه
في بكين والتي كانت خطوه نحو تحسين
العلاقات بين البلدين هذا الامر كان هدفا
اعلنته واشنطن اكثر من مره عسكريا وسياسيا
الابقاء على خيط دبلوماسي مع بكين والهدف
ابقاء المنافسه معها مع تجنب اي سيناريو
كارثي ولذلك جاءت خطابات الثلاثه لاداره
بايدن في ابريل مفردها ان واشنطن ترفض
الانفصال اقتصاديا عن الصين لكن بغض النظر
عن نجاح زياره بلنكن للصين او فشلها فهذا
الامر لا يعني بالضروره ان القادم افضل في
مايو الماضي خير مثال لقاءات وصفت
بالصريحه والبناءه والجوهريه بين مستشار
الامن القومي الامريكي ونظيره الصيني وما
جاء بعدها ايضا كان توترا متزايدا
لكن الايجابيه رغم التوترات الامريكيه
الصينيه هو ان كلا الطرفين سيحتاج للتعايش
مع الاخر كقوه عظمى ربما اي قناه واشنطن
هذا اخيرا قوه الصين الاقتصاديه وصلابه
الحزب الحاكم يجعلان سيناريو نهايه حاسمه
لحرب بارده اخرى امرا شبه مستحيل لكن
التصريحات لا تساعد ولا حتى الافعال بعد
زياره بلينكن جاءت زياره اخرى لكن الى
واشنطن ومن من خصم الصين الهند بكين تعترض
والمواجه مستمره يمكن
خدنا
قديما كانت حقوق بث الرياضات المختلفه
تقتصر المنافسه فيها على القنوات
التلفزيونيه لكن مع تطور الهائل الذي
نعيشه المنصات الرقميه المختلفه الشركات
التكنولوجيا كانت لها كلمه اخرى واحده تلو
الاخرى تستثمر شركات مثل ابل امازون وجوجل
مليارات الدولارات لشراء حقوق بثي رياضات
مثل كره القدم وكره القدم الامريكيه
والبيسبول لكن السؤال ما سر هذا الاهتمام
اولا الربح شبه المضمون من المتوقع ان
ترتفع عائدات باقات الاشتراكات في البث
الرياضي من 13 مليار دولار العام الماضي
الى 22 مليارا و600 مليون دولار في عام
2017 زياده ثلاثه وسبعين في المئه في خمس
سنوات المشاهدينا اما السبب الثاني وهو
الاهم جذبوا ملايين المشاهدين الى الخدمات
التي توفر البث الرياضي مثل ابلباس
وامازون برايم لثاني تمثلني مدخلا لمنظومه
منتجاتها المترابطه يرفع فرص الاستخدام
لخدمات اخرى تابعه لها على سبيل المثال
اول مباراه بثها امازون برايم لكره القدم
الامريكيه شاهدها نحو 9 ملايين شخص مقارنه
بثلاثه ملايين ونصف المليون شخص شاهدوا
خلال نفس الليله حلقه المسلسل الاكثر
مشاهده في الخدمه
وبينما كان المعدل السنوي للمشاهده تسعه
ملايين
ملياران ونصف المليار دولار راهنت بها ابل
على قدرتها المساهمه في ارتفاع شعبيه كره
القدم في البلاد حتى الان تشير ارقام
المشتركين في الباقه باقه الدوري الامريكي
لكره القدم الى نجاح تخطى توقعات الشركه
الاعلى قيمه عالميا التجربه كانت ناجحه مع
دوري البيسبول الرئيسي ام بي
بهذا نكون قد وصلنا الى الختام حلقتنا
وتتابعنا غدا في الساعه ستون ماذا ينتظر
افريقيا بعد تمرد فاجنر في روسيا العقارات
الايه للسقوط صداع مزمن في راس المجتمع
المصري
[موسيقى]
في نهايه الساعه ابرزوا احداث الساعه بصور
من الان وحتى الساعه المقبله انا حنين
الشولي وهذه الساعه 60
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات